In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinha Xadion for June 3, on which we commemorate our venerable and
God-bearing Father, Kevin, abbot of Glenda-Lach.
St. Kevin was from an Irish family of the royal line.
His birth was announced to his mother by an angel, and after his baptism he was confided
to the holy monks of the monastery of Kilna Manach for his education, ordained a priest
who withdrew to lead a solitary life in a deserted place called Glenda-Lach, the valley
of a hundred lakes, south of Dublin.
Unknown to the world he lived there, a life entirely consecrated to God, dressed in animal
skins, and with no other food but nettles and sorrel, spending whole nights in the freezing
waters of the lake, where a monster lived, in order to read the Psalms.
It is said that he spent seven years standing, his arms crossed, and without shutting his
eyes.
A bird made its nest in the palm of his hand, and the saint only lowered his arms after
the hatching and flight of the nestlings.
From such striving he acquired such favor with God that the angels seemed to accompany his
prayer and trees bent their branches as he passed.
Disciples quickly gathered round the man of God wanting to imitate his heavenly life.
As he had no other care than to persevere in prayer, the Lord saw to their needs and an
order brought them a fresh salmon every day.
But when one of the monks conceived the idea of killing the animal for its beautiful
health, the order disappeared.
The saint, having then settled the community a little farther away, this monastery became
the center of a veritable monastic city, where it was said thousands of monks were gathered,
contributing greatly to the spread of Christian culture in eastern Ireland.
On his return from a pilgrimage to Rome, Saint Kevin brought back with him a great many
relics of the saints, who worked miracles through his intercession.
After long years spent in the spiritual direction of his disciples and his people, he fell asleep
in peace at the age of 120 in the year 618.
Saint Kevin was venerated among the greatest Irish saints, Patrick, Bridgid, and Columbus,
and his monastery became one of the four main pilgrimage centers in Ireland.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.